she's the best she's the best actress
that's Pete Davidson gushing about
girlfriend chaseui wonders and it's no
surprise a source tells E.T the couple
is very in love and so cute together
our source says of that cute moment
between the bubkist co-stars at the
series premiere Pete was feeling a
little overwhelmed since there were so
many people there but when he was with
Chase he was instantly comfortable they
were canoodling and having a great time
together I've been fortunate enough to
have some great relationships and you
know uh honesty is always really
important the chemistry between the two
is also translating on screen in bubkus
a peacock comedy series Loosely based on
Pete's life looks like Chase plays his
love interest you run away from people
who love you I don't do that I mean like
she's gonna Crush she has a lot of cool
stuff coming so at a blast but this
wouldn't be the actress's first time
flirting with Pete on screen what is she
doing here
the pair co-starred in the 2022 film
bodies bodies bodies where's Maxie not
responding my text
Jesus
romance rumors between the pair first
sparked in December at the time our
source said their connection is natural
and Pete likes that she is down to earth
and cool since then they've been spotted
cozying up on a date at Florida's
Daytona 500 and and even here he was
just visiting at my house with his new
girlfriend yeah at Martha Stewart's Farm
around Easter time the lifestyle Guru
shared this sweet pick of the couple who
she says was touring the town of Bedford
New York and Martha she gives chase her
stamp of approval lovely lovely and our
source says things are lovely between
Pete and Chase adding the actors very
into her and she's the best she's a
sweet girl and they are a good match
foreign